I was behaving in a way that I thought
would make other people like me and what
that meant was the people who did like
me I didn't actually truly like if
you're trying to befriend somebody
because they have something that you
want and you try to pretend that you're
at their level to say whatever it is you
think they want to hear from you so that
they feel comfortable befriending you
it's very transparent that that is a
false and shallow gesture so I think
it's important that if you want to
attract a certain caliber of person into
your life then you have to live your
life in accordance with the kinds of
values that would be attractive to that
person and as somebody who's spoken a
lot about dating this is the same thing
with relationships right you're not
going to attract that mate who is living
a more aspirational life than you until
you can level up your own life